[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you just tapped into the group chat live
in the bleacher report app presented by
fanduel i'm greg ivory alongside live
moves live your nuggets
they lost the tough one on the road last
night but the joker he tied larry bird
record for all-time triple doubles
talk to us talk to us left talk to the
people how are you feeling on this fine
tuesday
i'm trying to stay very calm about the
snuggets team right now i'm trying to be
patient with them the injuries this team
has faced this year are definitely
taking a toll murray isn't back first it
was mpj now it's dozier so i really
think that this nuggets team kind of
needs to hit the refresh button when it
comes to their defense uh in the games
they lost last night all their starters
had 14 plus points so offensively this
nuggets team isn't really struggling on
defense they are and as great as jokic
is he can't do it by himself so i think
they kind of need to re-establish those
roles with all these injuries this year
and hopefully pull it together but i'm
not going to hold my breath i'm trying
to stay calm and just relax
liv is staying calm she's staying
relaxed about her nuggets
i'm staying calm and i'm kind of staying
relaxed about my bets later tonight uh
but we're excited we're excited to have
you back on the show live and as always
we're giving away locks and we're giving
away jerseys and we're giving away
hoodies so you guys get in the comments
and do what you do i need gifts i need
emojis but most importantly live on this
show the people know
we want winners
and winners only please uh
today i just mentioned tuesday it is tnt
tuesday fanduel is boosting the 3x2 in
not one but two both games tonight
making it three
by tuesday the question is will there be
two three pointers in the first three
minutes of the game today we asked you
on twitter which three by two will catch
tonight
is it the nets the maps the celtics the
lakers here are the results liv
tell me tell me tell me
are you is this like i don't even i
thought this would be the other way liv
i honestly thought this would be the
other way but i need the people in the
comments to tell me which three by two
do they think is a lock
lift both of these three by twos are
plus money
which one do you like best
i'm kind of with you i thought that we
would see the numbers a little bit
differently so it looks like i'm fading
the public here i mean
both plays are great plays however
considering the fact that both brooklyn
and dallas allow the top 10 fewest
threes i don't love that play right off
the bat as for the celtics lakers
matchup in the last two games two threes
have been attempted by the celtics in
the first three minutes now it's a
matter of will they make them that's the
tricky part but what helps them tonight
is that the lakers rank bottom 10 and
three-pointers allowed and defensively
they guard the three-point line at an
average rate so i like if the celtics
team kind of continues on that same
trend they're putting up three-point
shots early on not to mention you've got
a lakers team that has the second
fastest pace so i will i could imagine
if the celtics are you know putting up
three-point shots early the lakers will
do the same they like their games very
fast pace so
i'm leaning lakers celtics in this three
by two to be honest with you but now i'm
feeling a little nervous because it
looks like i'm fading the public i'm
fading the twitter the twitter people so
we'll see how
liv from betting experiences there is
nothing wrong when fading the public
there's nothing wrong with fading the
public um i'm in the comments though i'm
in the comments seeing if they rocking
with you i'm seeing if they going
against you
but it looks like
it looks like they might be rocking with
you i got ripe sick saying the celtics
aren't getting past
a d and lbj tonight
love the take love the take uh shout out
to you you're walking away with a hoodie
i am also in the comments i see
maxwell rexel maxwell rexell says
boston la shout out to you max you were
walking away with a hoodie i also see
joey in the comments joe yan's in the
comments shout out to you joe joe's
rocking with boston la uh some other
people are also julio hernandez is
rocking with the nets and maps shout out
to you mgoblue nets mavs uh i'm i'm
gonna call it though i'm gonna call it
liv i'm i'm gonna make a decision
we are all writing your play live
sending you good vibes sending the good
vibes to la uh we're riding the boston
la three by two tonight but why not ride
the other one sprinkle on both right get
get less money on both like like
let's all ride together why not
we asked you in the app we asked you
guys in the app who will be the top
scorer in tonight's boston la
lakers game at the end no get in the
comments and tell us in the comments and
tell us what you think at the end of the
game we'll dm one random person who
guessed correctly and hook you up with a
jersey let's take a look at the current
odds live you see them right here on
your screen
what do you like what's standing out to
you
so if i want to play it safe i'm going
to lean jason tatum because of the
celtics performance the last time that
they played the lakers however a little
bit of a hot take coming from live moods
really quickly i like dennis schroeder
at plus 1000 i think the value is great
and it's worth a little sprinkle out of
all of the opposing positions the lakers
give up the most points to that point
guard position an average of 24 points
to be exact so they definitely struggle
to defend guards dennis schroeder is
coming off of a 31 point game against
the trailblazers he's obviously going to
be feeling himself going up against his
former team he had 21 points in the last
meeting against his former team so at
plucks 1000 i think it's worth a
sprinkle for dennis schruter i really do
look at liv throwing that curve ball at
us man throwing the curveball not taking
a safe pick i like that liv i actually
do like that my guy's facing his former
team uh
he's facing his former team usually when
guys face their former team they step up
so uh
she's rocking with dennis schroeder i'm
gonna be i'm gonna play it safe here liv
i'm going to play it safe here i'm
rocking with lebron i'm rocking with my
man lebron james simply because it's a
big game tonight boston la lebron
usually shows up in those big time games
in the lakers they've been up and down
up and down all season it's time for
them to uh
to kick it into gear and to get going
and the only person that's gonna do that
for them the only person that you know
that leads this laker team is lebron
james so i see him having a big game but
it's not about what i think it's about
what you guys in the comments think i
see little reno lil reno 23 says
a.d he's rocking with a.d tonight plus 3
30. shout out to you i got can't guard
cut says bing bong
russ is scoring the most
with 36 and eight he's going for 36 and
shout out to you kent garcon love love
the take jay shy 13 says it's gonna be
tatum for sure so shout out to everybody
in the comments shout out to everybody
that i mentioned you all are walking
away with hoodies please remember
after the game we're gonna hit up one of
you guys and hook you guys up with a
jersey live it's time for the
my favorite part of the show let's talk
major markets money lines against the
spread and point totals for tonight's
game there it is let's take a look at
the odds liv
what are you seeing here and what do you
like
well when i'm looking at that nets
mavericks game i definitely like under
221 60 of dallas games have gone under
this year and 56.5
of brooklyn's games have also gone under
both teams rank top 15 for fewest points
allowed to their opponents so i'm liking
the under there
as for the celtics game i can't believe
i'm saying this but celtics plus four i
like it the last time these two teams
met the celtics won by 22 points and
both teams were healthy right now we
have a questionable lebron a
questionable ad i know that they will
likely play we know what questionable
means in the nba it's kind of pointless
honestly
but they won by 22 points last game and
i know they had that home court
advantage last time but this celtics
team on the road is not bad they are
nine four and one against the spread
when on the road so them not playing at
home is not really a disadvantage in
terms of them against the spread and
because of the way they dominated the
lakers last time i think i'm gonna take
the points with the celtics at plus four
i like that a lot liv i i actually like
that a lot let me hop into the comments
let me hop into the comments before i
give my take uh i got
i got
nets win i got next win m go blue shout
out to you um i got maxwell rexella's
back into the comments shout out to you
max he's rocking with the nets he's
rocking with the next night i'll talk
about that hitman zaza says lakers minus
four everybody that i mentioned you're
walking away with a hoodie let me hop in
here then
i was looking at i was looking at the
graphic and i and i was like oh i see
two i see two that i want to take i know
we were supposed to pick one but then
you come and drop two on it so it's like
i gotta drop two it's it's like
mandatory that i dropped two for the
people and we're gonna first start off
with brooklyn
look at the minus one and a half
they have kevin durant on their team
that's why i'm betting on brooklyn they
simply have kevin durant on the team
this is like a pick em this is basically
like a pick em i like the better team in
my opinion the brooklyn nets here uh
need james harding to to score do a
little score and do a little
facilitating i like the brooklyn nets in
the first one and the second one liv i
like your pick i love the boston celtics
plus four i actually bet boston in the
first matchup in boston when they won by
20 plus points and that was a rocking
chair win it was a rocking chair victory
i was able to sit back relax enjoy it
laugh a little bit call up my buddy it
was a real good time watching my bet
cash with no sweat so uh i think i'm
gonna rock with that one again liv
so uh shout out to liv she just threw
the curve ball at us with dennis shooter
and she also threw the curve ball again
with the two picks
so live you're you're you're on the road
today you you are on the road today we
talked major markets now let's talk
player props it's time
for lock or not i'm gonna put up a prop
and i need all of you guys in the
comments to let me know
whether it's a lock
or it's not
live is you ready to get this one on are
you ready to get this one started
i'm ready let's go let's jump into it
let's get right to it let's get right to
it the first up we have my guy i just
talked about him late i just mentioned
them james harden to score over 21 and a
half points
tonight
in his matchup versus the mavericks the
odds are currently at
live
what do you think this lock or not
i actually think it's a lock i do i
really do i think james harden is
currently trying to figure out his role
on offense with this nets team and i
think this is a great game for him to do
that some of his strongest performances
have come when he's facing a bottom
ranked defensive team and that is the
mavericks the mavericks also have a
really weak perimeter defense in terms
of threes and we've seen james harden
can hit the three-pointer
the three-point shots with no problem so
if he can get that started from the
beginning um and stay hot from the three
and and you know find opportunities to
score so he can really establish his
offensive role on this team i think it's
definitely an easy catch so i like it
i'm taking the over i think it's a lock
liv's taking the over she thinks it's a
lock
i'm gonna also take the over i think
it's a lock simply because i just said
that i'm betting on the nets tonight to
win that ball game and in order for them
to win that ball game
we know what kd brings he's a walking 28
easy walking it could be quiet it can be
loud it can be aggressive it could be
non-aggressive but kd is a walking 28 we
know what he's gonna do
but james harden we need we need you to
go over tonight in order for that betcha
cash so
come on man we need you to go over 21.5
points go score some points uh next up
next up liv next up is porzingis
to record a double double it's sitting
at plus 165 lift talk to me do you like
it do you love it no maybe so
i don't love this one to be honest with
you the nets rank bottom 10 and rebounds
aloud so i could see him maybe hitting
over
10 rebounds tonight but the nets also
have a top 10 defense in terms of fewest
points allowed to their opponent and
he'll be guarded by kd all night i just
don't think porzingis is the guy to stop
that kd defense and to score a lot
tonight so the scoring worries me a
little bit i think he can definitely get
some boards but i do worry about points
liv
unfortunately
i'm gonna go on the other side here my
man chris taps hasn't played in two
games
i think he's gonna have some fresh legs
lift i think he's gonna have fresh legs
go get 10 10 you know
fresh legs i know kd is guarding them
but uh yeah he didn't play in the last
two games i'm banking on him to have
fresh legs to get 10 and 10 so i say the
double double might be a lock let me hop
into the comments let me hop into the
comments uh i got lil reno loreno says
not
shout out to you little reno ball is
life says no way shout out to you ball
is life you're walking away with the
hoodie uh let's move on live let's move
on finally we have kd
to score three or more three-pointers
and it's sitting at plus
146 live talk to me talk to the people
we're talking about the grim reaper
we're talking about my guy kd here
do you like it or do you not
i don't i really don't as as strong of a
score as kd is he can find opportunities
to score from wherever and at the
three-point line
i don't love this play i mean he's only
hit this over in two of the last 10 and
when you've got a team that's full of of
shooters that can shoot from the
three-point line there's no need for a
guy like katie to be standing in the
three-point line prioritizing
three-pointers all game so i don't love
this for him he hasn't hit it very
consistently
and there's other guys on this team that
can get those three-point shots and it
doesn't have to be katie so i don't love
it
i like your take lift i don't love it
either i don't love it either uh can he
do it yes will he do it i don't know do
i want to put my money on it
not really i see kd like i just
mentioned he's a walking bucket he's
going to get buckets in all facets of
the game buy the basket mid-range he
might hit a couple threes but three of
them i don't know i'm not putting my
money on that one uh
liz
let me give away a hoodie let me give
away a hoodie let me hop in uh
hitman zaza hitman zaza says kd three
plus threes is lock shout out to you uh
goat garden says no for kd
shout out to both of you guys you both
are walking away with hoodies all right
liv
it's time to build our br betting custom
parlay which you guys that are watching
you guys can ride along with us on
fanduel tonight on inside the nba my guy
chuck charles barkley is gonna look at
our parlay and choose his best leg while
i give out the parley i need everybody
in the comments to tell me what they
think which leg is a lock which leg is
not
which leg
is gonna
cash early which leg is not gonna cash
early you guys just give me all type of
takes in the comments this week we're
looking at the game we've been talking
about most of the show it seems like liv
the boston celtics taking on the los
angeles lakers
are you ready to get into this one liv
yeah i'm ready let's do it let's do it i
love a good same thing
after it
lives ready i'm ready the people in the
comments i hope y'all ready cause the
first leg we are rocking with
is my man
lebron
james it is taco tuesday too lebron
james 25 plus points tonight live talk
to me talk to the people do you like
this one do you see him scoring over 25
i mean lebron has had 30 plus point
games in the last three games
i'm sure he's gonna be looking for a
little bit of revenge after being
dominated by the celtics team earlier
this season and to me this is the kind
of game where lebron james will want
full control on offense to make sure the
job gets done exactly how he wants it to
get done so i don't think he has any
problems hitting 25 plus the only reason
i could see it not hitting is if they
prioritize a d as the score in this game
because ad is questionable and coming
back i'm not sure but again this strikes
me as the type of game where lebron
steps up as that leader and says give me
the ball and i'll make sure we win this
game so i like him to hit 25 plus
oh yes yes yes starting off with good
vibes from live moves is always a good
thing let's move on to the next leg of
the parlay the next leg
you mentioned them scoring but we're
talking about rebounds here liv can aed
go grab eight rebounds tonight
well so in a perfect world
lebron would be the priority priority in
terms of scoring and a.d would be that
quote-unquote big man
so he shouldn't have a problem hitting
this my only fear is i'm not sure if he
hit this last game against the celtics
the celtics are a pretty average team
when it comes to rebounds so there's
definitely a lot of opportunities there
for him to get these boards it's all a
matter of how this lakers team shows up
we've talked about it before i talked
about it last season um when they were
acquiring all these new guys and had all
this new talent this lakers team is hard
to read and their roles on this team are
are very different and they kind of
change every game so in a perfect world
lebron is scoring a d is the big man and
and this shouldn't have a problem
hitting but
those roles man i feel like they're they
switch around they're playing musical
chairs with their roles on offense and
defense sometimes so it can be a little
confusing
you definitely have a point with that
you definitely have a point with that uh
they're they're finding their way
they're trying to find the way i was
actually talking to ron or tess about it
the other day about the lakers trying to
find their way and uh fit into their
roles that is meant for them to play uh
moving on to the third leg of the parlay
it is my guy russell westbrook
he's a newcomer on this lakers team
he's been up and down this season with
but six assists
that seems low to me what do you think
i love this leg of the parlay i think
it's easily my favorite leg um russell
westbrook we saw him really showing out
in terms of scoring on this lakers team
in in recent weeks but that was when we
didn't have a d and we didn't have
lebron with these two guys on the court
i think that russell westbrook's main
priority should be facilitating i think
he should be focusing on getting
rebounds and getting assists i don't
think scoring should be his priority um
i think he this is the type of game
where when you've got a healthy lebron
and a healthy a.d ad
he just needs to facilitate the ball to
them so i like him to hit this over i
think six plus is easy money for him
this is the guy that is the walking
triple double so you know i like him to
do that tonight definitely be a
facilitator tonight not necessarily
prioritize scoring but facilitating
absolutely so i love this leg
i called my man the walking triple
double yes
he used to be he he did he used to be
not so much anymore
uh
but let's move on let's move on to this
last leg we got the good vibes from liv
on that last westbrook six plus assists
this one um i'm
honestly kind of skeptical about we got
jason tatum three plus three pointers
live
how you feeling on this one
well
the lakers are allowing uh the bottom 10
they're they're allowing the bottom 10
most rebounds in or i'm sorry
three-pointers in the league right now
so i don't hate this play at all i think
jason tatum is the type of guy where
he's gonna take the shot
will he make it is the question of the
year he's gonna take the shot no matter
what again this is a lakers team that
has a very quick pace they're gonna get
started and get hot right off the bat um
and jason tatum if those lakers start
pulling a lead that's a little too big
for his liking he's gonna pull up from
the three and he's gonna stay there and
he's gonna shoot the ball so how will
this lakers team show up and defend the
three that is the ultimate question here
but we know that jason tatum is gonna
take the shot we know that if they have
any sort of deficit he's gonna sit at
the three-point line and try to fix that
um so i like this three plus
it's a little it's a little nerve
wrecking just a little bit but i
definitely think
yeah he's done it before so
let's just hope he does it again
yeah yeah i mean let's pray and hope
that he does it again uh liv
let's pull up this ticket let's pull up
the tickets so we can show the people at
home
what this ticket will come out to be if
you put a hundred dollars on you walking
away with 450
liv now it's time
for you to grade the be our betting
parlay so what are you great in this
library
i'm gonna give it a b today i'm gonna
give it a b uh don't hate it
uh there's a there's a couple little
aspects that make me nervous i think any
time you take a threes prop you should
be nervous any time because
it's one of those props where they'll
take the shots that should absolutely
have made you hit that bed and they're
just off and that's that's the reality
of a threes prop so those obviously make
me naturally very nervous and then
what will the roles be for the lakers
tonight they have a lot of really strong
guys that have a lot of talent um but
everyone needs their own role everyone
needs to stay in their lane and so
depending on what that lane is tonight
there are a couple of those plays that i
think could make us nervous and we'll
definitely be sweating this one out till
the end so i'm going to give it a b
because it's a good same game parlay but
it's not going to be an easy one that's
for sure
hey b
3.0 that's honor roll i'm gonna take
that i'm gonna take that uh i'm in the
comments right now liz i am in the
comments
giving away hoodies and i'm also giving
away a jersey i got nicole marquez greg
and liv i will give you a b-minus on
this parlay lebron won't make 25
especially after being out for so many
games i know he's here to beat the
celtics and beat everyone tonight a.d
and lebron are the dream team but i do
think 80 and russ will take over the
scoring tonight winners only manifesting
new jersey love the take you're walking
away with the jersey spicy angel is in
the comments saying a minus
jason tatum is the only one that is
bringing this down the other three could
all be locks thank you spicy angel for
the good vibes uh i got one more in me
live i got one more hoodie in me
i'm looking for a good take here i got o
l o seven uh five six gives us an a plus
and says hammer it
i love that i love the vibes shout out
to you uh shout out to everybody that
commented shout out to everybody that i
mentioned you are all walking away with
the hoodie live
steve kerr has repeatedly called my man
draymond green the best defender in the
world green proved it again
on
friday against the suns
he became the first warrior to ever
record nine points nine rebounds nine
assists six steals and three blocks
he's number one in the league in
defensive rating and his teammates are
calling for him to win 2021 defensive
player of the year live i need everybody
everybody here to get in the comments
and tell me if draymond should win
defensive player of the year and if not
who do you think should win let's take a
look at the oh the odds are already up
draymond is currently sitting that plus
150 lift
is that good value and what are your
other favorite bets on the board right
now
i gotta be honest i think draymond green
is my favorite i haven't really
considered anyone else at this point do
i think plus 150 is great value it's not
great but do i think it's going to get
any better than where it's at no
especially not if this warriors team
continues on the path that they're
headed down right now they are hot um
one thing about this this defensive
player of the year any award for that
matter is i think it's a popularity
contest and i think in order to secure
an award like this you've got to be on a
winning team and draymond green is right
now this warriors team is hot i think
this warriors team is capable of winning
it all so draymond green is in a really
great spot right now to you know to be
awarded defensive player of the year i
am very excited about the version of
draymond green that we have right now i
feel like there were a couple years in
there where he was kind of playing
insecure basketball and i don't mean
that in a bad way but i think he was
trying to figure out what he was best at
and when he prioritizes defense and
doesn't worry about how many points he
puts up
i think we're seeing him in his best
form right now and i absolutely love it
because i bet on this guy a lot last
year and i would take his points or his
points plus rebounds and i would get
screwed a lot because he's just not
meant to be focusing on offense like
that you have guys on the warriors that
are taking care of that for you they
need a guy like draymond to focus solely
on defense and he's doing that right now
and he's doing it well and i think
that's why the warriors are able to be
so successful so i'm loving this version
of draymond green and i think he is the
best choice right now for defensive
player of the year
i'm loving this version of draymond
green as well liv but i i think when
draymond has his shooters around when he
has his shooters around he feels
comfortable he knows what role he needs
to play so uh i'm also gonna ride with
draymond green barring injury i think
this is a runaway i think draymond runs
away with this one uh he's plus 150 for
a reason i'm in the comments though i'm
in the comments
looking for good takes i got
mike hale cannon says draymond is a good
finisher and blocker i disagree on him
being a good finisher but he does block
a lot of shots you're walking away with
hoodie uh qb coach one no qb one coach
says absolutely he's the defensive mvp
for the nba best team yes yes yes
warriors are the nba best team uh i got
one more in me one more in me
wait jay shy if j shy 13 threw a
curveball at his lift he says miles he's
the he leads the league in blocks and
the value is nice
wow
wow okay uh shout out to you jay shot
you are walking away with the hoodie hey
everybody that i mentioned you all are
walking away with a hoodie
so shout out to all you guys liv i think
it's time unfortunately i think it's
time to take this on home i think it's
time to get on out of the group chat
thank you guys thank everybody for
tapping into the group chat presented by
fanduel remember what you learned today
the brooklyn dallas 3x2 is a lot
draymond green should win defensive
player of the year and make sure you get
on fanduel to tail our br betting same
game parlay and my man
charles barkley make sure y'all tune in
to inside the nba nba pregame show to
see charles choose his best leg of our
parlay cannot wait we'll be back next
week we'll be back live giving away
hoodies giving away jerseys giving away
locks and if you won today if you won
today we will dm you not me not live
moves but be our betting will reach out
and dm you so make sure you guys get on
fanduel ride with us and follow us on
socials
alongside live moods i'm greg ivory we
are leaving the group chat peace
[Music]
so
[Music]
you